I need you to help me find my son your
boy was snooping around some not-so-nice
guys he's my son this situation is
complicated trust me on this one
don't make this man angry a reward for a
job only half done a means of preventing
them from tracking you by way of your
sonic scream and the job was done to
perfection
I thought the objective was to take down
the Internet you know the objective was
to take down the firewall protecting the
vault and miss Smoak was most adept in
complying
why couldn't you find a way to do it
yourself I've been doing this too long
to leave trails in his lands much safer
to have his smokes digital fingerprints
on the processor not mine and once she
had taken down the firewall I was able
to upload a critical piece of code to
our plight what happens now
take the next step
[Music]
hey everybody Deathstroke is back let's
break this down if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get everything
there'll be new flash ring giveaway
stuff at the end of the video too so
we'll start with Deathstroke then I'll
talk about Michael Emerson from last
night's episode the schedule is a little
bit weird because the World Series was
this week and they also released Thor
Ragnarok so there's just like so much
stuff all dropping at the same time but
as you can see it's going to be a field
trip with Oliver and Deathstroke and
present day to go rescue his son from a
Russian province the flashbacks will
also tease Deathstroke's origin story
how he wound up on the island and it
even looks like we see Billy
Wintergreen's Deathstroke mask here
because the color is so different from
Deathstroke current version of his
costume so there's a whole bunch of
Deathstroke stuff happening in the arrow
universe and because the Titans TV show
is happening and they're doing
Deathstroke stuff in the movies there's
a lot of questions about what the future
of the character is going to be on arrow
so I'll talk about that in a second but
most of you probably know that Joseph
Wilson is one of Deathstroke sons from
the comics Grant Wilson is technically
the first version of ravager most people
no Ravager is Rose Wilson the TV show
did a version of her in Isabel rochev so
they're ravager was a little bit
different in a way back once upon a time
when they sunk the ship in the pilot
episode they intended for Sarah to come
back as the Ravager character but then
they ended up changing the plot a whole
bunch originally they intended for
Deathstroke to be a much bigger villain
in season 1 so when they sort of found
the show and figured everything out a
little bit better they decided to push
Deathstroke to season two and become the
big villain of that season and made
Malcolm Merlyn the big villain of season
1 and then because of that they also
decided to turn Sara into the first
version of The Black Canary remember
they just called her the canary in the
rest is history but it's always fun to
hear what their original plans for the
show were way back before season 1 so
even though they have all this
Deathstroke stuff happening they have
Deathstroke flashbacks I'm expecting
them to still flash to team arrow just
like a little bit in the episode but it
does seem like most of the episode will
focus on this Oliver storyline which i
think is why episode 4 sort of like that
big felicity
Cayden james team up was so different
from what you would typically expect an
arrow episode to be I mean the episode
was called reversal so literally it was
the roles reversed Oliver was the man in
the chair instead of being the man out
on the street you'll all probably agree
that he feels like he will turn into the
big villain just like the way he sounded
so devious and so manipulative of
Felicity someone who's supposed to be
really smart but in the episode she even
said I'm having trouble seeing the
things that are right in front of me
like it's a very arrow thing that they
make a lot of mistakes early in their
hero career so Felicity is making a lot
of Oliver season 1 season 2 mistakes
where you don't completely pick up on
all the clues right away so his big
villain plot is called arc light is
basically just controlling the internet
so that he can turn things on turn
things off blackmail municipalities
governments just control pretty much
anything that's connected to electronic
circuitry but that sort of in its early
stages and it sounds like he's going to
be able to throw Felicity under the bus
because now her fingerprints are on the
firewall that needed to be taken down so
that he could gain access to all those
systems so he's playing all the
characters like fiddles Oliver doesn't
really know what's going on now but
eventually he's gonna put the suit back
on it'll be more like classic team arrow
then maybe by the mid-season finale
maybe the second half of the season then
it becomes more of a team arrow mayor
Oliver Queen problem because if Caden
James is going to be controlling the
infrastructure that governs a lot of the
services that the city benefits from
then people like regular people will
start freaking out and it will become a
big problem for mayor Oliver Queen in
addition to the green arrow and then
obviously you have black siren working
for him they also confirmed that he was
that person that helped her off the
island in episode 1 I think we all
thought that and now it sounds like
Richard dragon is gonna be more of the
drug dealer big kingpin type villain so
we'll see if there's any intersection
with Kate and James and Richard dragon
but it doesn't seem like that's gonna
happen right away he's also going to
debut in the next couple of episodes too
and we'll learn about the jingle-jangle
or whatever drug it is the Diggle is
taking if you want to believe the
Riverdale theory of everything is
connected like the drug the killer frost
is taking too
herself out in the drug the Diggle is
taking to balance himself is all the
jingle-jangle that they've been selling
on the Riverdale TV show but there's
just sort of a running joke because
technically Riverdale isn't supposed to
be connected to the DC TV shows but just
a reminder that the death stroke episode
is actually two episodes so it'll be
episode five and then the week after
that episode 6 episode 7 of arrow is
going to be like a Thanksgiving type
episode so I don't know if a william is
going to be in the next two episodes but
it's going to be william heavy in
episode 7 and that will lead into the
crossover episode because just like
previous seasons episode 8 will be the
four night crossover of most of the TV
shows circling back around - Deathstroke
stuff in the future because they confirm
that they're making a death stroke solo
movie it makes it harder for them to use
the character on the TV show in
eventually they'll probably start using
the character on Titan's so it does make
it a lot harder for Manu Bennett to come
back on arrow as the character and he's
sort of busy with other TV shows but I
don't think his time as the character is
completely done and there's always the
off chance that they might use him as
the Deathstroke of Titans when he does
eventually pop up there but that might
not be till the second season it just
depends on how hardcore the movie people
are about letting the character appear
on TV but Manu did say that he talked to
Marc Guggenheim about doing a death
stroke spin-off TV series and even
though I don't think it would ever
happen
they basically confirmed that if they
did do something like that it would have
to be on a different network so that it
could be extra hardcore the way you
would expect them to do that TV show
it'd be kind of like The Punisher like
you couldn't do that on ABC or CBS or
even the CW nobody wants to see the CW
version of The Punisher speaking of
which that series will be dropping in
two weeks I'll be doing videos for it
there will probably be a new trailer in
the next couple of weeks there is a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Desir elated comment on the
video congratulations to the winner from
the last video
Jack Woolridge please private message me
so I can get your contact details click
here for my Thor Ragnarok post-credits
video and you can click here to learn
all about Roy Harper on
season 1 thank you so much for watching
come buddy stay awesome I'll see you
guys tonight